bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france sur quels faits vous êtes
vous basez pour déposer cette plainte
alors on s'est fondée sur les éléments
pouvant apporter nos clients c'est à
dire les victimes ont des éléments
anciens que des éléments plus récents
concernant l'enlèvement la torture et
l'assassinât d'ib et déjà on sait fondée
sur les déclarations d'ibrahima
coulibaly lui même a plus qu au moment
de mourir juste avant il a déclaré dans
un média c'est guillaume soro qui
m'attaquent
après le lendemain de grafite son
cadavre a été publié dans un quotidien
très proche de soro et puis en 2015
on a un enregistrement avec deux
personnes qui parlent et ces points sont
attribués à maçonner d'un côté et à
guillaume soro d'un autre côté et la
voix attribué à guillaume soro ironise
sur la mort d'ib et en disant ah
qu'est-ce qu'on en serait là s'il était
encore ici ces délais les éléments qui
sont sérieux y en a d'autres et puis sur
les les massacres de 2004 qui
interviennent là aussi dans un contexte
d'épuration des personnes qui sont
proches du du leader ibrahima coulibaly
donc on a des éléments qui sont sérieux
pour nous pour déposer une plainte
aujourd'hui en france et on espère
qu'une enquête sera menée
on aura d'éléments justement au plan
juridique très concrètement que va
permettre cette plainte alors sur le
plan juridique
comme il s'agit de créer des crimes
rares on demande la saisine d'un juge
d'instruction sans passer par le par le
parquet pour que les actes d' enquête
soit diligentée pour entendre les
victimes puisque nous on a six personnes
qui ont décidé de porter plainte
aujourd'hui certaines concernant l'effet
de 2004 les massacres et crimes de
guerre
et puis d'autres concernant la
disparition du bep que ses compagnons
donc ce qu'on espère nous c'est que
guillaume soro qui est en france sera
entendu qu'il aura à répondre des
soupçons qui pèsent sur lui aujourd'hui
et que la justice sera sereine en
traiter cette affaire parce que
justement votre plante en fait elle va
permettre de réclamer la désignation
d'un juge d'instruction qui mènera les
infos les investigations et ça sans
passer par une enquête préliminaire du
parquet n'ont finalement c'est une
enquête qui se ferait plus rapidement
rapidement je sais pas en tout cas c'est
une enquête qui 2
ce faire pourquoi on la dépose en france
et pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est très
simple nous on travaille sur cette
plainte depuis plusieurs mois on a été
en contact avec toutes les personnes qui
nous ont saisis
et puis on a la fidi b qui portent
plainte qui a 15 ans aujourd'hui qui est
française donc elle est française et
elle elle comprend pas pourquoi les
personnes qui ont commandité
l'assassinât de son père et qui l'ont
assassiné n'ont jamais été entendues
dont on sort on est en france ça ne
donne compétence pour porter plainte
maintenant et puis il a plus de mandat
puisqu'il avait fait jusqu'en 2015
lordon place mon immunité aujourd'hui il
ya plus d'immunité et si parce que j'ai
entendu qu'on d'instrumentaliser la
justice je ne crois pas on a un victimes
françaises guillaume soro est ici et lui
n'a pas hésité il ya quelques mois en
janvier à déposer plainte en france
contre le procureur ivoirien donc voilà
c'est parce qu'il réside justement en
france depuis fin 2010 9 que vous avez
aussi décidé de déposer cette plainte
oui c'est aussi pour ça c'est ce qui
nous permet de le faire aujourd'hui de
manière sereine on considère également
que sa fille est la victime directe de
l'assassinât donc on aurait pu même s'il
n'avait pas été là déposer la plainte
mais c'est vrai que c'est un bon
concours de circonstance donc c'est pas
une plainte d'opportunités c'est les
victimes ça fait des années et des
années qu'elle se bat pour essayer de
mettre un terme à l'impunité mais en
tout cas pour nous aujourd'hui en france
c'est le bon moment et puis on a
beaucoup travaillé on est prêt c'est
aussi pour ça est ce que vous pensez au
plan diplomatique que la france puisse
vraiment intervenir alors que guillaume
soro est candidat à la prochaine
élection présidentielle en côte d'ivoire
écoutez je l'espère on a mon exact qui
sont extrêmement graves
on a des soupçons qui sont réelles on a
une victime française
on avait des crimes qui sont atroces
donc j'espère que les français se
penchera sur cette affaire en dépit du
calendrier électoral ivoirien que c'est
pas pour cette raison on porte plainte
qu'on n'est pas des pantins on avait des
personnes qui nous ont contactés qui ont
souffert pour certaines dans leur chair
en tout cas pour perdu des des êtres
très proches dont on espère française
saura saisir cette plante mais vous ne
craignez pas que que la côte d'ivoire
puisse accuser
paris d'ingérence ah bah c'est pas la
question et puis de toute façon la côte
d'ivoire pourra vous ai parlé
d'ingérence sais pas c'est pour cette
raison que nous on dépose pas on ne
pense pas parce qu'on a des victimes qui
veulent savoir et qui ont des raisons de
soupçonner guillaume soro et hic c'est à
dire toute personne qui aurait pu
commettre ces crimes ce soit en qualité
de dar d'ordre du commanditaire docteur
autres complices merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions de rémy essaïdi coach et je
rappelle que vous êtes avocate d'une des
familles plaignantes